le transport aérien en plein crash
l'année 2020 a été catastrophique pour
le secteur les mesures sanitaires liés à
la pandémie de covile 19 ont cloué la
plupart des avions au sol les chiffres
sont vertigineux 66 % de fréquentation
en moins au niveau mondial le chef
économiste de l'iata l'association
internationale du transport aérien brian
pearce ne mâche pas ses mots
c'est le plus gros choc que le secteur
aérien n'ai jamais vécu
l'impact sur les compagnies aériennes
est colossal elles ont perdu 5 110
milliards de dollars de chiffre
d'affaires en 2020 des pertes
financières qui auront aussi de graves
conséquences sur l'emploi
selon les estimations de l'iata à 40
compagnies aériennes sont sur le point
de disparaître en europe selon lui
european cockpit association environ
18000 postes de pilotes ont été
supprimés ou sont menacés sur 65 mille
les moyens de subsistance de 11,3
millions de personnes dans le monde
dépend directement de l'aviation 76,4
millions de jobs supplémentaires sont
dans le tourisme dépendant de l'aviation
impact qui se ressentira aussi sur
l'industrie aéronautique en france le
groupe airbus a baissé sa production de
près de 40% en 2020
l'avionneur américain boeing a encore
enregistré en janvier plus d'annulations
que de commandes d'avions et les
perspectives d'une embellie sont
limitées le groupe air france klm ne
s'attend pas à un regard de trafic avant
le deuxième voire le troisième trimestre
2000 21 pour le transport aérien
le redécollage sera l'eau